I'll save you time so you can move on
it's good this is a ludicrous concept
because first of all it's real
life you know just the passion that
people have to eliminate Merit and Truth
in real life
is my problem like listen I got plenty
of ideologies myself but when they start
going into delusion land there's so much
important importance in
competition eliminating it and taking it
out of these kids and giving these
eighth place trophies and saying
everyone's a winner when the game was
played and you saw that wasn't true it's
people up competition is
phenomenal it teaches it builds
character people reacting to losing
because they have a deeper issue inside
that may be challenging and something
that needs to be addressed but
competition it's real life